are you tired of being chained for not
keeping up to date with the latest web
technologies does your longing for the
golden years of the World Wide Web go
unappreciated by your colleagues are you
a webmaster here sit on top the only
conference for 99 never-ending cartoon
under guard dreamweaver hypertext markup
language macromedia flash marquis bow
our users xml cascade style sheets yeah
how much would you expect to pay for a
deal like this $400 $300 275 dollars two
hundred and ninety-nine dollars 275
dollars and eighty nine cents two
hundred dollars 400 300 know if not only
do we have 1999 technology we have 1999
pricing twenty dollars a ticket that's
right only twenty dollars a ticket
tickets are selling fast don't wait to
get yours boot up your computer and type
in http/2 lane' forward slash forward
slash HTML c 0 and f dot com once again
that's http/2 lane' /¸ /¸ d html5 oh em
enter until them crockford sencha